this morning iran's Foreign Minister
says any attack on his country would
lead to quote all-out war president
Trump says he is in no hurry to do what
he calls dastardly things in response to
a missile and groan strike blamed on
Iran that damaged Saudi Arabian oil
facilities Ian Lee is in Saudi Arabia's
capital Riyadh Ian what led to this
Iranian response well as mentioned Iran
said that any military strike against
that country will see Swift retaliation
and that warning coming as Secretary of
State Pompeo was talking tough to in a
diplomatic show of support Secretary
Pompeo met with Saudi Arabia's Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman and said that
Saturday's attack was an act of war
in a tweet Pompeyo called the attacks
unprecedented and said that Iran's
behavior will not be tolerated you can
see the type of the UAV yesterday the
kingdom made their strongest case yet
that Iran was behind the recent attack
the Saudi military displayed some of the
18 drones and seven cruise missiles they
claimed were used Saudi hasn't responded
militarily to Iran when when is the
breaking point we are working to know
exactly the launch point and would we
have it we would have the evidence and
the decision is not in my level Saudis
military claimed these weapons entered
from the north of the country but
stopped short of saying the launch point
was in iran iran denies being behind the
attack that damaged half of saudis oil
production but US officials also say
unreleased satellite photos show the
most damning evidence yet the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard preparing for the
attack at Ava's airbase in southwestern
Iran from there the weapons flew through
Kuwaiti airspace roughly 400 miles to
their targets in Saudi Arabia a team of
UN investigators is coming to Saudi
Arabia to independently go over the
evidence meanwhile president Trump is
set to meet his new national security
adviser tomorrow to discuss ways to
respond to a run short of going to war
Tony Ian Lee for us on the ground again
in Saudi Arabia Ian thank you very much